gaiman eine der beliebtesten
freizeitbeschäftigungen bei kindern über
spieler foren schließen sie auch
freundschaften und hätten somit der
ganzen welt wer aber am anderen ende
sitzt weiß man nie genau das birgt
gefahren
[Musik]
der tatort im internet ein missglückter
weg dahin kilometer gewonnen
aber im internet ist nur es muss klick
in einem fall der vor zwei jahren in der
schweiz und in deutschland schlagzeilen
machte
bringt ein erwachsener übers internet
einen jungen dazu sich mit ihm zu
treffen
das fordert uns vor zählt der seite
gleich ins dorf spieler mit kollegen
haben abgemacht dass es politischen
selbmann und sagt sie der einsätze das
schafft nicht so kommt dann sehr schnell
gesagt das war ja man sieht dass man
sich als einziges team spieler und dann
ein serienmodell tricks wird und muss
jetzt eine der folge sind sie denn uns
verständigt
der zwölfjährige paul verschwindet
spurlos die polizei geht schon bald von
einem verbrechen aus
[Musik]
einer großen öffentlichkeit und auch
mehr als mutter wird plötzlich bewusst
wie schnell ein internet kontakt
schlimme folgen haben kann
eltern wissen meist wenig über die
digitale welt in der sich ihre kinder
bewegen
ich recherchiere in der gamer und
youtuber szene und entdecke eine
dimension wie alles andere ist als
kinderkram
[Applaus]
[Musik]
erste antworten finde ich bei vater und
zur und bodmer als journalist verfolgt
marc büttner die gamer szene seit jahren
und schreibt regelmäßig über die
neuesten trends
ein glück für seinen sohn shawn der
spielt sehr gerne und pflegt so auch
seine sozialen kontakte zusammengespielt
und classic findet zwei sekunden
games sind insbesondere für jungs als
großes thema mit definiert sich über das
game das gespielt was es heißt wenn ich
wenn ich jetzt um die spiel call of duty
spielen dann bin ich in der regel die
call of duty spieler oder ich spiele
battlefield spiel
das sind zwar verstehen dass bei
ziemlich genau gleich ob das kriegt
genau wie ich aus wie wenn ich jetzt
sage ich bin ein fcb verein oder für den
verein geben ist mittlerweile ein stück
jugendkultur hat die möglichkeit zu
hause vom sofa aus mit anderen zusammen
zu spielen ist vor allem bei jungs sehr
beliebt die kantonspolizei solothurn
fahndet im sommer 2016 auf hochtouren
nach dem vermissten paul und geht
verschiedensten spuren nach
eine task force arbeitet tag und nacht
und wertet alle hinweise aus
also sind nach informationen von einer
älteren war auf seiten sehr viel segment
nicht bewegt viel online games spielt
und das natürlich ein informationsbüro
mir aufgenommen und an den weg sei die
oas köln im internet oder innere
bekanntschaft oder im e mail verkehr in
den bistros sie war sehr viel geredet
hat die beamten werten die computerdaten
und chartverläufe von pauls computer aus
im fokus steht vor allem das spiel
minecraft ein online game in dem man mit
anderen spielern schatten und sich so
über spielzüge und strategien
austauschen kann
ist denn minecraft ein gefährliches
spiel vorliegt und im konnex zum
internet was man eigentlich das spiel
ein multiplayer-modus schauspieler dass
man dort mitspieler hat team porten
corner von lüthi moment ich nicht weiss
war das gemisch sondern sind einfach
spielen und dann irgend eine enorme
zunahme der stadt ihre identität als
dritter in kontakt tucson chat
bekanntschaft mit dem spiel wo man
einfach nicht weiß war das gegen übrig
paul hat oft minecraft gespielt es ist
eines der erfolgreichsten computerspiele
überhaupt ein einfaches lego ähnliches
klötzchen spiel in dem man ganze welten
bauen stories entwickeln und auch
kämpfen kann
minecraft gehört microsoft und wurde
bisher weltweit rund 122 millionen mal
verkauft minecraft weiß man natürlich es
ist üblich sehr viele kinderspiele es
kreiert dies spiele dieses spiel
eigentlich mit der asterix bietet comics
in der älteren akzeptiert ist also
vertreter hans einen relativen hohen
teil auch hinterher mit youtube ist aber
noch etwas anderes möglich geworden
jeder kann sich beim gamen filmen und
auf youtube stellen
die guten spieler tun dass fast täglich
und millionen von kids schauen ihnen
dabei zu
markant die welt bewegt sich die team-
und fordert eine sag jetzt mal wirklich
spannend wie wenig an roger federer zur
sorge wenn ich tennis spiele der hans
einfach besser als sie und da hätten
größten vorsprung und und und er hätte
die wichtigkeit wurde das spiel
bitte sag ich jetzt gründen oder zu dass
sie natürlich noch eine spur was sie
will keine wirklich gut rät sie mit
witzig sie und wenn sie das wenn sie die
kombination mit also mitbringen
einer dieser letzte player ist der 23
jährige däne
er gehört mit über drei millionen
followern zu den größten youtube stars
deutschlands
die neuen helden unserer kids zeigen auf
ihrem youtube kanälen nicht nur wie sie
spielen sie lassen ihre fans auch
täglich an allen details ihres
privatlebens teilhaben face camps und
smartphones machen es möglich
[Musik]
die größten youtuber im
deutschsprachigen raum sind krank und
sarah sah in der erwachsenenwelt kaum
bekannt werden die beiden als stars
gefeiert
bohlen wichtige preise ab und sind den
talkshows sehr gefragt
[Musik]
und wir wollten das eigentlich gar nicht
so machen wir wollten eigentlich nur
spiele reviews machen für so ein online
portal wo wir über spieler reden und da
gab es da sie weit über diese szene
gestolpert und haben angefangen selber
auch mal einfach diese videos voll zu
quatschen mit irgendwas was einem gerade
einfällt ja irgendwelche spontan wird
teilweise auch aus dem eigenen leben so
ein bisschen erfahrungswerte mitzugeben
bis moralpredigten vielleicht und das
ganze ist dann irgendwann eskaliert und
keiner weiß so genau warum eigentlich
die beiden haben zusammen über fünf
millionen fans trotzdem wirken sie nicht
abgehoben sondern wie kumpels von
nebenan
marc bodmer und ich wollen wissen ob
sich die youtube stars ihrer
vorbildfunktion bewusst sind und wie sie
mit dieser verantwortung umgehen
franck und sarah zu kontaktieren scheint
einfach sie sind auch verschiedensten
social media kanälen präsent sie sind ja
längst nehme nur youtube ist im
konventionellen sinn machen wird mehr
als nur ihre game videos sondern sie
machen die verschiedensten sparten
update bis zu reisebericht und und
dokumentarfilm für fernsehkanal unter
glich at t nämlich auch wird sophie
scholl gehören derzeit zum überwinden
das übernimmt dann kann es 223 oder oder
es tatsächlich direkt auf das ist
beziehen
über die adresse dann muss man noch was
zu grund
zurück zum vermissten paul drei tage
nach seinem verschwinden findet die
polizei im nachbardorf sein fahrrad
die auswertung der daten von seinem
computer hat in der zwischenzeit ergeben
dass paul in minecraft hat eine seltsame
kommunikation geführt hat
die schottin glas misstrauisch gemacht
hat de niro das ist jetzt doch
eigenartig schrieb jetzt wirklich davon
lieferte körpers zum spieler und nicht
das sind natürlich die sachen gesehen wo
mannschaftlich vertiefte angelegt haben
und eine vitrine mit den schritten
können
eine überwachungskamera hatte zudem
bilder von paul in begleitung eines
unbekannten mannes aufgezeichnet bestand
am anfang noch die möglichkeit dass paul
davon gelaufen sein könnte
verdichtet sich für die polizei nun der
verdacht dass er von einem
pädokriminellen den er über den chat
kennengelernt hatte entführt wurde
das ist natürlich ein potenziell trinken
und pädophilie ein relativ gutes gespür
dafür bist jetzt oder nicht jedes kind
ist verschiedentlich gefordert deutsch
heutigen zweiter sondern es sind
eigentlich ihr kind war vielleicht der
größte bedürftigkeit kann und eine meter
vor sich zum internet vertraut und dann
passiert das auf einem falschen gespürt
dass da springt auf mich und den konnte
seine komposition stand und den bergmann
begrüßte zieht denn das
vertrauensverhältnis und den kosten
einfach verdauen an den auto wenn man
sich dem motto bisher trifft und dieser
junge ist zwar auch erst zwölf jahre alt
aber er gehört wohl nicht zu den
gefährdeten kids
dazu kennt er sich in der gamer welt
viel zu gut aus bei minecraft spielen
und schatten hat er es oft auch mit ganz
unbekannten zu tun und so gut dass und
ihnen sagen wenn die gut drauf sind dann
fertig hast du noch mit dem stylus
geräte und statt 1000 sich irgendwie
telefonnummer noch voraus dass man mit
den arbeiten dort und ich liebe mit dem
skype ein verhalten dass viele eltern
erschrecken würde aber damian weiß dass
sich im netz seltsame gestalten tummeln
er glaubt aber nicht dass man pädophile
von den games fernhalten kann direkt
blockiere das internet funktioniert
nicht und dann in blockiere
damian war von klein auf fasziniert vom
gamen
seine eltern waren mit einer situation
konfrontiert wie sie viele eltern
bestens kennen
ja das klingt vielleicht ein 2 2 2 2 2
das wichtigste ist dass er mit der euro
ist wichtig dass er mit europa retter so
dass man irgendwie transparentes
mannschaft somit zu verbot er lernt aber
träger aus netz und david regler
vakanten wonach er befolgt will's netz
die befolgt aber für uns ist vor allem
wichtig dass er hosen im verheimlicht
und der rechte glaube ich ein gesetz
erfolgt was erzähle dir brennend meine
frage und was nicht was darf man also
888 solches verhalten nicht woher hast
du wohnst du also schneller starten und
wenn du nach
[Musik]
und es ist profilbilder was ich durch
dieses gesicht und er hat danach die mit
dem bösen bedeutet also gleichzeitig ist
er gerne zu und stieg dann aber
schlussendlich blog was hast du diesen
kontakt nacht klickten aber da kann ich
immer noch andere kontakte aber er hat
nicht nur unterstellen
woher weißt du das veräußern heißt das
neue wie man das macht internet google
seit einem jahr produziert damian wie
viele andere kids nun auch filmchen für
seinen eigenen youtube-kanal inspiriert
natürlich durch den erfolg der großen
youtube
[Musik]
nach zwei wochen das jetzt tatsächlich
spiel minecraft und das haben wir dann
hoffentlich stellt damit man die zeit
ich muss mit meinen kräften und es macht
einfach so stolzen youtube kanal eine
rezeptur showbiz biete im moment hat er
20 abonnenten
aber er hat große pläne wenn ich jetzt
zum beispiel coole musik film oder
ziemlich mies lettische video und
lackiert wurde ich dann mussten wir
jetzt mich nieder zu machen
ich ernenne zwei büchern macht sich zur
musik ein bisschen träumt er schon davon
auch ein youtube star zu werden
vater und sohn bodnar schauen sich an
der logisches um das ist die größte game
entwickler messe in der schweiz
hier werden neue spiele vorgestellt und
investoren gesucht
youtube stars suche ich hier jedoch
vergebens
also mir hängt die wäsche nein aber es
ist berechtigt die frage warum haben wir
das nicht ich danke mir seit sonntag
nichts nur dass mir stets schweizer
premiere mit vor der kamera und locker
zu ihrer fotokamera mir hängt auch nicht
so wahnsinnig viel international
erfolgreichsten komiker
ich danke gott dass ich letztlich muss
man ja was so verkaufen und so
präsentieren dass es wirklich lustig ist
im game entwicklungsbereich hat die
schweiz überraschenderweise die nase
sehr weit vorne
die 27-jährige philomena schwab zum
beispiel hat ein spiel entwickelt für
das sie vom forbes magazin vor kurzem
als eine der 30 besten game
entwicklerinnen ausgezeichnet wurde
[Musik]
es ist schön sie die aufmerksamkeit
generiert und zwei interviews dafür ganz
natürlich immer super für schweizer
industrie an irgendwen erfolgsstory fort
wiese hat es hilft alles also als
patrick geldpolitik von kreditwirtschaft
zum game entwickelt
doch wirklich mit ihrem kollegen hat sie
nun ein startup gegründet zusammen
arbeiten die beiden bereits an einem
neuen energie ihr erstes game war ein
evolution spiel für kids
fühlt philomena sicherheits game
entwicklerin irgendwie verantwortlich
für ihre jungen kunden definitiv rosi
verantwortlich wir sind eigentlich die
droge designer also mit und eigentlich
versuchen erfolgen und experience
designer wurde spiele möglichst
effizient und möglichst lange behalten
und gerade je nach dem mit was würden
wir finanzierungsmittel dass man das
dann kombiniert als man sich das auch
zum beispiel alle kennen die kranich
steht schon als ziel es war wichtig zu
machen und denen dann berufsbild
altersunterschieds ziehen und man muss
sich schon gut überlegen
die richtige von games ein abdriften a
die logisches zieht vor allem ein junges
publikum an
ich spreche mit philomena auch über den
fall paul jetzt muss ich mir überlegen
als in die entwicklung hat man meistens
ein budget kann man nicht die ganze zeit
irgendwelche lied auf seine server
laufen und aussteller beginnt kontrollen
machen
ich denke dass laura später ältere dass
sie viel geld wie durch sind die kinder
drinnen und was für kontakt hansi und so
will eigentlich ist es game wo man sich
trifft hier wird wirklich besonders als
chat forum srf polizei im internet
abdeckten
mark hat auf seiner interview anfrage an
die großen youtube stars krank und sarah
sah keine antwort erhalten
ich probiere es ebenfalls mit dem
gleichen resultat so zum greifen nah wie
sie vorgeben sind die neuen helden
unserer kids offenbar nicht ich versuche
es noch bei anderen großen youtuber
ebenfalls ohne erfolg
bis ich bei meiner recherche auf eine
künstleragentur namens studio 71 stoße
ein blick ins netz macht klar die
agentur managt viele bekannte youtube
und akquiriert fleißig neue talente auch
aus der schweiz die besten werten zu
einem weekend nach deutschland
eingeladen nicht nur gamer sind
attraktiv als potenzielle werbeträger
auch junge musiker komiker sportler und
beauty & food bloggerinnen werden hier
ausgebildet
[Musik]
ja es ist alles einfach total groß es
ist atemberaubend also ich habe so was
noch nie erlebt ist angekommen in unsere
zimmer rein und da lang dann die handys
von the way die neue branche ist hoch
professionell organisiert es geht um
viel geld um wie viel genau darüber
redet niemand
[Musik]
sturm waffe ein anderer großer youtuber
gibt tipps
hier mache man bei anderen gruppen auch
bei leuten die seit jahren und machte so
die fehler gemacht haben
auch ansturm waffe ist nicht
heranzukommen
er verlangt tagesgagen die für uns nicht
in frage kommen
aber vielleicht geht doch noch ein
türchen auf man stellt mir ein interview
mit dem youtuber kef in aussicht nie
gehört den namen aber vielleicht der etf
bereit sich mit mir zu treffen
ich warte wer übrigens meint beim
youtube hype handle sich um ein urbanes
phänomen wird in der nähe von la chs der
14-jährige silvan filmt sich bei seinem
neuesten rapp komponiert hat er ihn
selbst
nun macht er noch das video dazu die
kulisse ist die terrasse seines
elternhauses er hat vor allem spaß an
der musik und filmen gamen interessiert
ihn nicht so sehr
alle meine fans da draußen wartet auf
mich doch jetzt bin ich dabei mit einem
neuen berichtet all meinen ideen werde
ich wieder auferstehen
[Musik]
yeah
ich hab mir meiner kleinen welt weil ich
mich die ganze zeit wohnen abhält das zu
machen was ich will
was versagt vor zweieinhalb jahren hat
silvan youtube für sich entdeckt also
ich als 300 abonnenten am abend ziemlich
lang braucht bis man mal die 100
abonnenten erreicht hat buch simmel lang
und dann geht so es denn das ziemlich
schnell und wie plötzlich asche ganzen
recht der ruf immer wieder wieder tun
sie da klang bestehen als premier jetzt
mal sie hat jeder ziemlich lang bucht
wird sich stärkere zeit
wir haben eigentlich nicht das ziel aber
sicher ich möchte wieder hin wie das
mache ich jetzt total film fame mit dem
werde ja nicht aus youtube
wer sich öffentlich exponiert muss mit
reaktionen rechnen und auf youtube geht
es nicht immer zimperlich zu und her
die schlachten und die verdienen
schlachte kommentar ist
du bist noch viel zu jung für youtube
und und du bist bist du 11 jahre und 6
und aber die rechte meistens alles was
alt wirklich aus ständige kritik wird
zum beispiel nächstes mal könnte so dass
ein tag besser machen oder das finde ich
nicht gut die sache aber nicht
beleidigend dass sie wie viele kids ist
auch silvan computer technisch fitter
als die meisten erwachsenen
das machte vor kurzem in der schule
probleme
silvan mag nicht darüber sprechen aber
seine eltern mussten antragen die
schulung ist denn hat einfach eine zu
aggressivität dürfen und hat denn das am
kolleg zeigen und der kollege der andere
kollege zeigt am schluss hat sie quasi
die ganz gewiss denn der lehrer
natürlich hatte hinterher ist und den
sie im ricordo worden und dann das
gespräch mit der schulleitung und so
wird verständlich und konsequenz dass
ich denke sie dass man halt betrag ist
er unterlag dem asset ag ist von der
apple dafür hole und grünen unterstützte
die normal für irgendwie
wir uns also darauf an dass der user
kann und das tutorial
immerhin hat das ganze in der schule
einen positiven impuls ausgelöst
außerdem speichert sukzessive märkte
zwei jahre sondern auch wenn gruppen
entwickelt für kinder weiß auch ein
spezielles kiel setzte sich dort sind ja
noch andere der wird er wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr davon profitieren aber dass
man die quasi das unterstützung denn er
fördert und das finde ich total gut
die meisten schulen sind im digitalen
zeitalter jedoch noch gar nicht
angekommen
an den informatik tagen in zürich stelle
ich fest dass das digitale klassenzimmer
immer noch als zukunftsvision
vorgestellt wird
digitale medien sollen erst mit dem
lehrplan 21 ein schulfach werden
entwickelt vom leben die passiert für
hüte für oben und dann eine zahl
zwischen national erlebt
danke dass sie gekommen
am beliebtesten ist an dieser
veranstaltung eindeutig in minecraft
ecke die cats spielen wie profis
interessierte eltern versuchen den
informations rückstand aufzuholen
diese situation kommt mir sehr bekannt
vor
[Musik]
sobald man als non digital native etwas
verstanden hat kommt schon das nächste
tor auf den markt
[Musik]
da
microsoft zum beispiel präsentiert an
den informatik tagen im schulhaus die
neue holen
[Musik]
und am hauptsitz lädt man schon die
kleinsten kunden zu minecraft spielen
ein
was macht microsoft denn um den wissens-
gap zwischen den digital chips und ihren
eltern zu schließen
für diese kreative kids an der eltern
nötig macht nicht nur in der klasse 10
mehr unterrichtet damit ältere
auseinandersetzen kennt wie er sie nach
einer kinder ev heimunterricht und also
halbes jahr keine sensibilisiert und da
zum teil wirklich aber zum wake up call
machen derzeit aussieht gebastelt und
vielleicht meint sie können oder doch
ein unrealistisches stehlik wild kind
und jugendlicher sind in der ära
digitaler welt man kann nicht meinen
können das verhindern
eltern kommen um ihre
erziehungsverantwortung nicht herum
aber die frage bleibt hat microsoft als
markt mächtiger player der mit der
digitalen entwicklung sehr viel geld
verdient nicht auch eine verantwortung
gefahren im netz zu minimieren oder
pädokriminelle auszuschalten
dieses buch im internet oder die
klimatische es wie gesagt thema für
firmen und privatpersonen und mir haben
das so genannte digital crimes unit
wohne dediziert die abteilung ist fügt
an das macht als große internet komitee
zwei identifizieren und verfolger und
das ganze mit personen und zwei tat sind
aber auch der neueste technologie ja wir
künstliche intelligenz machine learning
wie muss man sich das vorstellen möchten
das zentrum als physische zentrischen
dem sie in unserem campus in redmond bei
seattle in den usa aber die intelligenz
kommt es im ganzen internet und wird
auch der zeitzeuge mit komplizierter
algorithmen werden noch eine sache oft
deckt wurden immer normal sind und den
der nord- und isoliert und den zähnen
arbeit mit der behörde
das macht der kriminalität in reduziert
genau diese zusammenarbeit spielte auch
im fall paul sechs tage nach seinem
verschwinden hat man verschiedene
puzzleteile zusammen paul wurde gesehen
als er mit dem mann auf dem video in
einen bus gestiegen ist
für die kantonspolizei solothurn ist
klar dass er entführt wurde
man bangt um sein leben der größte
kürbis sehr sehr gefällt und das laut
stadt dort erleben so permanent und und
jeden tag war nicht wirklich wichtig und
wird der druck natürlich erhöhe dann
wenn man fürchtet sich sagen dass das
passiert und dass man nicht erfolgreich
ist
verschiedene spuren führen nach
deutschland
mein größter männliche person und ist
möglicherweise von deutschland und die
stadt 80 millionen i wohn und die große
um sofort hier personen zu
identifizieren
urs bartenschlager schaltet die
bundespolizei fedpol 1
diese schickt ein team nach solothurn wo
feldbusch das ist erst ein stück sie
auch vor der zweiten woche wo im verlauf
von mobbing kapo solothurn ausgeräumt
und gefragt hat mich sehr unterstützt
die innere relativ eine breite
fahndungsmaßnahmen über interpol in
deutschland auf pauls computer
entdeckten die polizisten das foto eines
mannes dessen identität mit der des
mannes auf den videoaufnahmen
übereinstimmt fortschritt sie damit
glücklich mit dem vortag noch bestimmen
mein credo mit dem foto mit der besseren
spielfluss im gesicht ihr handküsse
andere sachen aus dem foto sein und das
alles hat die ermittlung um ein großer
schritt voraus gemacht
der täter ist identifiziert nun geht es
darum ihn zu lokalisieren
matthias herter es täglich in kontakt
mit den deutschen
strafverfolgungsbehörden andere profile
soziale netzwerke können ausfindig
machen und eins von einem profil in
verbindung standen mit der spieler
plattform also ein server wo der darauf
spiel verwaltet hat wenn die bibliothek
meiner onliner trainer seine spieler
nutzen und das ist ein service sie
benötige schweiz gestanden ist und daher
mit unterstützung vom fbi in anspruch
die hand ein auto schäden schweiz und
der hat mit dem personal jedes staates
nach haiti geschickt zu dem server
wollen sie entstanden ist und hat das
theater in der stadt rheine mitteilen
zum einen das theater im moment an
spielern ist also online ins perspektive
der äußeren sagen wo das immer
gespielt wird also frühere trasse muss
jetzt der täter das spiel betrieben hat
und das ist sehr wichtig weil es sind
verschiedene mögliche aufenthaltsorte in
falco und für äußerst sicherheit von
kindern und am kopf verletzt werde
damit tatsächlich trend identifizieren
und zum kind gelange
und das ist notwendig sind dann geht es
schlag auf schlag
acht tage nach seinem verschwinden um
halb zwei uhr nachts stürmt die
düsseldorfer polizei dieses haus und
befreit paul aus der wohnung eines 35
jährigen kochs die polizei hat es
geschafft ihn durch ein undurchsichtiges
system von netzwerken und servern zu
tracken dass das die realität und die
digitale welt ist in der wir heute leben
wird mehr an der gamescom in köln
definitiv bewusst die größte gamer messe
der welt zieht jedes jahr
hunderttausende menschen an das gerangel
gleicht einem rockkonzert
auch mark und sein sohn shawn stürzen
sich ins gewühl
die digital natives generieren ein neues
wir-gefühl sich vernetzen und anstehen
an einer messe wie in einem
vergnügungspark gehört dazu und spiele
endlich haben wir von studio 71 die
zusage bekommen den bekannten youtuber
kev zu treffen der 27 jährige hat
mittlerweile eine fangemeinde von 1,4
millionen follower gehört also auch zu
den großen stars im deutschsprachigen
raum
ich habe auch noch nicht gegessen ich
habe mir tatsächlich 1 1 wünschen das
werde ich mir gleich günstig zu bemüht
soweit die leute haben spaß
hinter glasscheiben geschützt games und
kommuniziert cash life mit seiner
community
zwischendurch hat er ein meet and greet
mit drei seiner fans die es geschafft
haben ich freue mich wirklich riesig
wenn ich mal wir unterhalten uns hier
nicht
nicht vorangehen oder fragen wie ich
wie immer lockt er alles auf youtube was
in seinem leben passiert
damit hat er ganz schön viel einfluss
auf seine fans wie geht er mit dieser
verantwortung will ich wissen schon das
ganze mit mir selber vereinbarten mit
meinen werten und natürlich auch diese
werte nicht bewusst die wir finden den
zuschauern auch kef hat vom fall paul
gehört aber eine totale kontrolle wäre
seiner meinung nach übertrieben
man könnte zwar theoretisch tragen ja
auch es muss jetzt alles wo wenig sale
sich mit gelockt werden
aber die rechte aller für die
einschränkung weniger einzuschränken
macht keinen sinn weil die leute die
schabernack treiben
wir werden dann einen anderen weg finden
aber der die einbuße der rechte die
bleiben dann sozusagen für immer bei den
anderen geschnitten und im endeffekt im
endeffekt verliert nur die große masse
an rechnen aber der schabernack wird gar
nicht aufgehalten und das ist ein super
großes problem aber ich glaube das gibt
es ja in jedem lebensbereich
zudem glaubt er die youtube szene habe
durchaus möglichkeiten hier präventiv
etwas zu bewirken
was nicht weiter die idee sehr gut hin
und da gibt es ja sehr viele aktion auf
wie zum beispiel auch youtuber gegen
hass appelliert haben wenn man einfach
so videos gemacht werden für einen guten
zweck oder gesagt wird leute lasst euch
nicht verarschen
wenn euch das komisch vorkommt dann
müsst ihr den andern nicht glauben jeder
kann euch das gelbe vom ei erzählen
seid einfach vorsichtig es gibt überall
komische leute die szene wächst extrem
schnell und youtuber sind eine community
die immer mehr junge menschen
beeinflussen
caps agentin ist seit fünf jahren dabei
und hat diese entwicklung liegt
vor fünf jahren konnten sich die online
influenza die mit über eigentlich noch
relativ frei bewegen
heutzutage sieht das ein bisschen anders
aus gerade wenn man sehr
reichweitenstarke künstler und creator
hat sie müsse
das entweder maskiert oder mit einem
bodyguard durchlaufen weil innerhalb
kürzester zeit ganz viele fans wirklich
ihren star erkennen ein foto machen
wollen autogramm haben wollen und die
dann wirklich die gänge verstopft sich
nach draußen
was als spiel und spaß begonnen hat ist
mittlerweile total kommerzialisiert
[Applaus]
instagram dankeschön der filter muss ich
lenke nur was wirklich gut
hallo ich bin mache ich bin der rucksack
ablegen des volkes
ok der hype ist ja und freundliche art
unruhen
das heißt den alltag inzwischen also die
zuhause milch und jens christ ist
natürlich ein ganz besonderes und weil
halt alles sammeln und sagen die leute
wie spiel in mailand hat sich zu einem
vergnüglichen jailbreak am skate
responsibility also wenn du jetzt
natürlich millionen von fans
was heißt das für dich also das ist
natürlich sehr sehr schwierig ich muss
natürlich nicht sagen ich sehe mich in
der pflicht
es gibt viele leute die gerade aus
jünger finde ich bin ja schon einer der
eltern youtube würde ich sagen die
jüngeren die youtuber die haben
vielleicht noch nicht das gespür dafür
dass sind selber noch nicht soweit ich
aber sehe schon dass ich natürlich sehr
sehr viele leute beeinflussen
aber die leute wissen dass sich
durchgehend positiv gestimmt bin einen
positiven lebensstil fliege sehr
tolerant und sozialen und einfach
freundlich finden und ich glaube das
merkt man halt einfach an den man sieht
auch hier der ist kein rüpel unterwegs
alle stellen sich darauf ein
also da sieht man schon dass scheinbar
der erziehungsauftrag erfüllt wurden ist
okay so ich bin nicht für euch da ich
finde es schön dass sie hier kommen sein
weil du ja also nicht freut erreicht und
ich weiß das glaubt man nicht aber als
youtuber gewöhnt man sich niemals an so
was also wirklich niemals bei 99 prozent
der zeit sieht sich jetzt zu hause im
zimmermann hat zwar irgendwie die zahl
wachsen aber dass so viele leute noch
einmal das ist etwas außergewöhnliches
jedesmal cavs zwillingsbruder mike ist
inzwischen dazugekommen
er sei der bessere gamer sagt f aber
nicht so aktiv auf youtube wie er
nike gehört zu denjenigen die live für
ein großes publikum geben und mit dem
sogenannten spot im moment einen totalen
aufschwung erleben
die besten gamer werden in dieser szene
gleich wie topshots im sport gefeiert
freiwillig zehn sätzen zurück und laufen
durch die gegend ich habe mich da wo ich
zeigen wir sollen die unter dem trikot
haben hier leben und bin ich richtig
cool als da somit die auf jedem
schreibtisch im fernsehen mal schauen
ich bitte die beiden brüder um ein
gespräch mikes freundin begleitet uns
mike ist der ruhigere kev der
entertainer aber beide haben keine
starallüren verlangen kein geld und
stellen sich auch kritischen fragen also
das kann ich ehrlich gesagt nicht
bestätigen ich es ist ja jemand der
viele freunde hat rolle einfach ein
offener mensch sich gerne unterhält ist
er selbst verliebt weil er viele freunde
um sich schart das kann man sogar schon
dass das ein bisschen zutreffend ist
weil die generation immer mehr
ich sag mal oberflächlich wird jetzt
heißt es nur noch wie sieht man aus die
die mädels schminken sich immer mehr
die jungs müssen trainiert sein man wird
auch viel schneller beleidigt weil es
anonyme ist im internet also da muss man
darf aber auch nicht zu sensibel sein
und natürlich die ältere generation die
sieht youtube noch nicht mal als job
anders also auch erstmal und so unsere
oma opa die können dann doch irgendwie
verdient damit geld wie wie soll das
gehen und was hier wie das ist nicht
immer so sachen aber man darf jetzt auch
nicht zu sehr ein fahren natürlich für
die jüngeren ist das selbstverständlich
wiederum und man muss natürlich auch zu
dem stehen was man macht denn dann ist
das kein problem denke ich
ein großes geheimnis wie viel man für
die hinter ihm an krieg gegen die
hausfassade also wenn sie alle wissen
ich kann meinen lebensunterhalt gut und
ich kann gut davon leben aber es ist
jetzt nicht so wie viele leute sich
forschen es gibt diverse statistikportal
das kann nicht sagen wo man den
verdienst schätzen kann das ist viel zu
hoch also ich kann nicht schlechter von
leben man muss aber auch dafür bedenken
man gibt ja seine persönlichkeit so zu
sagen ich will nicht sagen auf ob man
gibt sie ja preis an viele menschen und
das sollte ja natürlich auch irgendwo
einen sehr gegenwert haben weil jemand
der im büro arbeitet der verkauf dass er
sozusagen nicht an so viele personen und
man muss bedenken man kann es nicht
unendlich machen
das heißt ich schätze mal mit 40 ist
dazu spätestens ab gefahren
die beiden haben mit youtube begonnen
als es noch underground kultur war das
ist mittlerweile mainstream ist stört
kämpfen
er macht sich höchstens sorgen dass
negativer content überhand nimmt
wenn jemand ständig beleidigungen rein
wird vielleicht irgendwelche fake sachen
sexualisiert oder homo vor oder was
wirklich was von content macht und das
ist halt dann problematisch wenn sowas
mainstream wird und viele leute sich da
was abgucken weil die kommen also viele
zuschauer werden dann einfach ins
negative beeinflusst weil sie die person
als vorbild sehen auch blind glauben was
da erzählt wird wie sich abwertende
homophobe oder rassistische tendenzen in
der digitalen welt entwickeln kann heute
niemand voraussagen aber die
pädokriminalität im netz ist heute schon
realität
am landgericht düsseldorf findet ein
halbes jahr nach der befreiung von paul
der prozess gegen seinen peiniger stadt
freiheitsberaubung und mehrfacher
sexueller missbrauch lautet die anklage
gegen den kopf
das urteil fällt mit fünf jahre
gefängnis und unterbringung in der
psychiatrie
erschütternd milde aus findet pauls
anwalt sind so schwerwiegend dass also
diese strafe war bei der auffassung
nicht ausreicht trotzdem alle
beteiligten sind erleichtert dass paul
noch lebt ganz wichtig findet matthias
herter von der bundespolizei aber dass
die öffentlichkeit und vor allem eltern
die richtigen schlüsse aus diesem fall
ziehen
das was eigentlich dazu dass ältere ihre
front ortega für ihre kinder und ihr
freund du dich für die schulkinder
wieder mich und warner ist zum einen
dass sie sich beschäftigen mit dem was
ihre kinder machen wirklich aktiv als
aufgabe das gesehen
ich muss mich mit deinem
auseinandersetzen ich war mir bis
erkläre mir das spiel erkläre was du
machst mir mit werner lüth dass du in
kontakt ist und das funktioniert auch
erster linie über ganz originell und
natürliche funktion wo eltern für ihre
kinder nämlich bezirk und über die
bezirks liebe zu ihm kontakt mit einer
scream gemacht und können reagieren
das durchgesetzt einfach ergibt vor der
neue generation und sie dem us to china
1000 statt was im zentrum steht nämlich
sicherheit oder und das findet jetzt mit
einem fall über die kommunikation für
kinder zu älteren stadt für ältere aber
wo sich interessiert wie das kinder
machen und sich sachen entscheiden
die digitale welt in die unsere kinder
hineingeboren werden entwickelt sich mit
einem unheimlichen tempo der immer
füllen bereits heute große stadien wenn
sie gegeneinander spielen die sports
heißt das neue massenphänomen
ob uns diese entwicklung passt oder
nicht wie vorbilder unserer kinder sind
andere
und wer wegschaut bringt sich um eine
gute gelegenheit an ihrem leben
teilzuhaben
[Musik]
[Applaus]